this is about bearing down on the most
vulnerable among us he believes that
it's up to a woman to make those
decisions uh and up to a woman to make
those decisions with her doctor i know
you've never faced those choices nor
have you ever been pregnant so i suppose
this means that joe biden is a woman now
which is news i mean that that is
breaking news we have the first female
president he's an old man with
well the wailing and gnashing of teeth
continues over the supreme court's
refusal to temporarily intervene and
issue an injunction over a texas law
that essentially prevents abortion after
week six
now here's the thing the supreme court
didn't overturn roe versus wade wish to
god that they had they have not
roe vs wade is a supreme court decision
that says that nationally speaking there
can be no laws
that severely restrict abortion under
most circumstances
this was changed by planned parenthood
versus casey in the early 90s which was
a case in which we learned that any law
that placed an undue burden on a woman
seeking to
have an abortion post-viability was
somehow unconstitutional now again
grab your magnifying glass look for any
of this in the constitution you're gonna
have a pretty hard time but put that
aside
this new case where the supreme court
turned down
injunction the reason they did so is a
specific legal reason
you can't issue an injunction on a law
unless the person has brought a lawsuit
against a person enforcing the law
so typically as i've said before if you
have a lawsuit
based on enforcement of a law you'll see
that the defendant in the lawsuit is
usually like the secretary of state of
the state
or against the attorney general of the
state that's pretty common
what you can't have is me sue the local
janitor to enjoin a law because the
gender is not the enforcement mechanism
and what's weird about the texas law is
that the state is not the enforcement
mechanism what the state does it creates
a private cause of action
which means that if i see an abortion
doctor
performing an abortion on a woman
i can now sue the abortion doctor for
violating state law and uh and get ten
thousand dollars out of the abortion
doctor which effectively shuts down
abortion clinics in texas post six weeks
okay so
this creates a bit of a conundrum for
the courts because
the lawsuit that was brought to
create an injunction here was brought
against
a judge in texas
now the judge in texas was not actually
enforcing the law the judge had sued
nobody the judge had not brought anybody
up on charges or anything none of that
instead
the lawsuit should have been targeting
presumably
a person who reports another person
right that person sues the person who
reported them and then that goes up to
the supreme court so the supreme court
said this is not ripe right this is not
we have not gotten to the point where an
actual legitimate lawsuit has been filed
you have to have what's called a
cognizable defendant it has to be the
right person who's being sued
this does not overrule
versus white it doesn't
okay again wish to god it had it does
not that would then revert the question
of abortion back to the states which is
where it originally was it already
gotten pretty liberal in places like
california and new york it was very
conservative in places like alabama and
texas
which by the way
is
how it should be absent some sort of
constitutional amendment to protect
fetal life
okay so
joe biden came out and he is fighting
mad over all of this
joe biden put out a statement
because his face doesn't move that well
anymore his statement says today texas
law sb8 went into effect this extreme
texas law blatantly violates the
constitutional right established under
roe vs wade so first thing if you
established a constitutional right by a
supreme court case it wasn't a
constitutional right
that's pretty obvious right off the top
if i said there's a constitutional right
to medicare established by the supreme
court in 1985 and it wasn't established
by the constitution was it
but put that aside because democrats are
frequently putting aside the
constitution
they say this is upheld this precedent
for nearly half a century well that's a
big deal i mean obviously if a case is
really terrible and it's upheld as
precedent for half a century we have to
leave it forever like plessy versus
ferguson which said that segregation was
totally fine should have left that
forever it was president for fully half
a century and plessy versus ferguson was
end of the 19th century brown vs board
wasn't until 1954. so you know
should have left it presumably i mean
that was half a century of precedent
no you think not
i didn't think so either the texas law
said joe biden will significantly impair
women's access to the health care they
need particularly for communities of
color and individuals with low income
now again i don't know why it would
infringe on communities of color and
individuals with low income particularly
probably actually it would infringe on
people who can afford to pay the fine
because those people are going to be the
people who get sued
but he says it outrageously deputizes
private citizens to bring lawsuits
against anyone who they believe has
helped another person get an abortion
which might even include family members
health care workers front desk staff at
a healthcare clinic or strangers with no
connection to the individual
okay that is quite unlikely that you are
going to see lawsuits launched against
the uber driver as the left likes to say
in these particular cases
now listen i'm not saying that this law
is well drawn i'm not saying that this
law is going to be upheld by the supreme
court in fact i think probably it'll be
struck down by the supreme court i think
the supreme court is probably going to
pair back planned parenthood versus
casey but they're going to look at
schemes like this one and they're
probably going to say that this is a
effectively turning private citizens
into state actors
okay but
the notion that roe vs wade was just
overturned is crazy
then joe biden says my administration is
deeply committed to the constitutional
right established in roe versus wade
nearly five decades ago and will protect
and defend that right
i mean hasn't the biden administration
done enough in the past few weeks to
kill americans to step in at this point
and insist on the killing of more
americans in the womb it's in the most
bizarre defense of the day shinsaki at
the white house was asked by a religious
news reporter about the fact that joe
biden considers himself a religious
catholic
and uh and yet is now backing widespread
abortion
shinsaki's answer was this was treated
by the media as a slay queen moment slay
queen
um yeah it's not
why does the president support abortion
when his own catholic faith teaches
abortion is morally wrong
he believes that it's a woman's right
it's a woman's body and it's her choice
why does the president of who does he
believe then should look out for the
unborn child he believes that it's up to
a woman to make those decisions and up
to a woman to make those decisions with
her doctor i know you've never faced
those choices nor have you ever been
pregnant but for women out there who
have faced those choices this is an
incredibly difficult thing president
believes their rights should be
respected
um so i noticed that um
she says here you're not a woman you've
never faced this difficult decision so
shut up so i guess what we're supposed
to take first of all i don't know how
she's assuming this male identifying
person's gender i've been told reliably
by this administration that men can have
babies this is what i have been told and
i believe them because they are a
reliable source
so if i'm told that men can have babies
i don't know what she's jabbering on
about about how he's never been in this
situation how does she know he's never
had an abortion or considered an
abortion she doesn't know any of that
just the fact that he has a penis
doesn't that shouldn't prohibit him from
from having thoughts on this particular
issue he might be a woman
and not all women
have vaginas according to this
administration also
her comeback to joe biden is not acting
super catholic and backing abortion is
you're not a woman you don't know
so i suppose this means that joe biden
is a woman now which is news i mean that
that is breaking news we have the first
female president he's an old man with
so um and and has considered abortion in
the past as a religious catholic so i am
pleased to learn all of these new facts
from jen saki what a slay queen moment
and you can't do the i am woman hear me
roar when you cannot define a woman it
makes it very very difficult we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first i've been talking about expressvpn
on this show for months why haven't you
gotten a vpn yet see i care about
protecting my data i don't want my isp
grabbing it and using it against me i
also don't want hackers grabbing it
because frankly it is my business this
is why i use expressvpn you should too
there has never been a more important
time to protect your digital rights this
is why i and thousands of my patriotic
listeners choose to secure our online
data by using expressvpn did you believe
a vpn isn't for you because you can use
the internet just fine without one well
here's the thing anytime you go online
your isp can see every site you are
visiting and are you confused about how
it works you shouldn't be because
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones that encrypts your network
data and reroutes it through a secure
server that means you can use the
internet more anonymously without having
your activity tracked you think vpns are
complex and only for tech experts nope i
am not a tech expert but expressvpn is
super easy you launch the app you tap
one button now you're protected it's
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they're
rated number one by both cnet and wired
they stand for my values now's the time
for you to join me take a stand take
back your privacy at expressvpn.com
get three extra months for free and a
one-year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get three extra
months for free visit expressvpn.com
ben right now to get started then you
have elizabeth warren who i noticed is
in the united states senate and ran for
president unsuccessfully while
identifying as a native american and joy
reid
who is a very famous tv show host being
paid nightly for her dumbass opinions
i noticed that uh they were on tv
together on my television screen
complaining how we now live in the
handmaid's tale
well on my television screen being paid
handsomely
to do so well backing abortion
just like the handmaid's tale
here they are
people
think it's hyperbolic uh when i tweet
about the handmaid's tale yes coming to
america yes
but i don't think it seems hyperbolic
now does it to you
no
so
you know
i lived in an america in which abortion
was illegal
when i was young uh before roe versus
wade
and when abortion is illegal rich women
still get abortions
women with resources still get abortions
women who have time and who have friends
in other places will still get abortions
so
what this law is really about is not
stopping abortions across the board
this is about bearing down on the most
vulnerable among us okay this is an
amazing thing okay so a few things one
she says that she grew up in a time when
abortion was illegal okay first of all
she grew up in a time when abortion was
legal in certain states second of all
was it the handmaid still then really
was like 1955 1960 1965 right because
rover's away wasn't until the early 70s
was 1970 the handmaid's tale for women i
missed that part somebody should ask her
that
she says that now we're back in the
handmaid's tale so was it the handmaid's
tale in 1969
i noticed a lot of screwing going on in
1969 i like woodstock so um was that the
handmaid's tale
i'm having trouble reconciling these two
things then i i i just find it
astonishing how the left has invested
itself so much in equity talk that they
can't even make their old arguments so
instead of saying this harms women as a
whole they are now forced into the box
of explaining to joy read on national tv
that really what this is about is
harming quote-unquote vulnerable women
rich women will be fine but this is
really not directed equally it is
literally a law that is directed equally
the law applies to all
so
the you know there's a famous joke about
the new york times that uh the the
ultimate new york times headline would
be asteroids who hit earth tomorrow
women and minorities hit hardest
right and that's kind of how the left
treats this sort of stuff it's like
there's a law we don't like the law
therefore it is the worst for the poor
and for women who are who are of color
et cetera et cetera
but it's it's a really awkward fit it's
really strange and off-putting and again
handmaid's tale really
where is joy joy reed is justifying the
afghan polar you want to look at the
handmaid's tale they're literally going
to shove women into basements in burkas
tell them they can never go to school
again or walk on the street without a
mail present they can't drive or they'll
be beaten
joy reid is totally up for that so it's
elizabeth warren but it's real
handmaid's tale kind of crap when in the
united states you have to get an iud use
a condom or take a birth control pill
instead of aborting a baby after it's
already been conceived
because by the way that is the other
alternative i love that the alternatives
posed by the left here
are that like birth control pills don't
exist so the the two alternatives
according to the left and marriage
doesn't exist either so the two
alternatives according to the left are
randomly get pregnant and be forced to
bear the child in the worst of possible
circumstances or
widespread abortion for all
i've noticed a bunch of gradations here
so for a long time before the rise of
the birth control pill the solution to
getting pregnant
out of wedlock was to not have sex out
of wedlock that was the solution for
virtually all of human history and in
fact people who did have sex out of
wedlock and then got pregnant very often
got married
if you look at the number of seven month
babies who were being born in the 1940s
the answer is a lot
okay then the birth control pill came
around and now you have a really easy
solution to avoid getting pregnant
without even getting married while
having sex and that is who use birth
control
and yet abortion is such a sacrament
that if abortion goes away they i mean
it's again remember they used to say
that abortion was really about
these tough situations where a woman is
whether it's about rape or it's about
incest or it's about uh some a baby with
a fetal abnormality or they don't even
bother with that anymore now it's like
it's pure birth control i don't feel
like using a condom i don't feel like
using birth control i feel like having
unprotected sex and if i conceive a baby
i feel like going to planned parenthood
or using plan b or whatever
when using abortion as birth control it
really starts to undercut whatever moral
case you have or even restricted levels
of abortion
and you have nicole wallace in msnbc
also on her high horse
john again in them in this moment
male governors in florida and arizona
and texas
don't want the body to be covered by
four inch piece of cloth against mask
mandates i'm going to reach deep into
the uterus of a woman and tell all of
them to carry up 85 percent of abortions
take place after the six-week
mark that the texas law bans what is the
real world effect here
male governors are reaching deep into
the uterus ooh deep into the uterus um
you know reaches deep into the uterus
abortion doctors killing the babies
inside the uterus i noticed just like as
a physical matter
actually going in and cutting up a baby
and then sucking its brains into a sink
that's that's physically reaching deep
into a uterus in fact what these
governors are doing is saying you cannot
reach deep into the uterus to kill the
thing that is growing in your uterus
which is a human
i'm also very annoyed i'm just i'm
highly irritated with the stupid
argument that men are not allowed to
have a perspective on abortion
why not we're mental we're
non-slaveholders allowed to have a
perspective on slavery after all they
didn't hold slaves they couldn't know
the the
difficulty of not having slaves
like that's not how any of this works if
you're trying to protect human life like
i have perspectives on why murder is
wrong i'm not a murderer myself i
haven't been in those circumstances
what a dumb argument
and there are plenty of women by the way
who are pro-life in fact
i would say virtually all of the
pro-life leaders that i personally know
are women
people like lila rose
over at live action
governor kay ivey right she's the
governor of alabama
she signed into law two years ago a law
that banned nearly all abortions
was she a man at the time how does that
work
well the good news is that um
at least robin d'angelo recognizes
humanity in the womb this is exciting so
robin deangelo the author of white
fragility the anti-racist activist uh
she now says that
racism was even affecting her as a fetus
all the self-contradictory language by
the left is amusing to me here we go
white people are invested
in the racist status quo for for lots of
reasons
um and i think it's unfortunate but i do
think we have to see it as in our own
best interests so a couple things have
to happen there one is
it's a little more abstract but it's
like you almost have to un
dismantle your very identity to the core
and rebuild it because even before i
took my first breath as my mother
carried me
in pregnancy the forces of race were
operating on on us
robin deangelo's a pro-lifer now guys
she was a human in the womb racism was
operating on her
well i mean i guess the answer for the
left is you can abort all the all the
kids in the womb i guess and then you
won't have to worry about future racists
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]